the whip whip reject nation we gotta
watch a couple of things first three new
tv spots everyone who messaged me this
on social media was saying like there's
a lot of new footage in here cool so i'm
going off your advice going off of your
words so there's a lot and the second
one is another clip from the movie peter
ruins runes i think it's what it's
called yeah all right guys we'll get to
it the bridge fight reaction was
uploaded earlier so you guys can go
ahead and watch that too spiderman
[Music]
truth is i accidentally brought those
dangerous people here
what whoa watching wish me luck
whoa what
broadcasting
your friendly neighborhood spider-man
could really use something
wow
that's a big reveal that spell gets
loose they're all coming here
wow
don't do this i have to try
exclusively in movie theaters
yeah
i know this is my message
and i swear to you that i'll fix it
but i'm gonna need some help i can't
believe i'm in the sanctum i'm saying
it's horror
neither can i exclusively on movie
theaters thursday yep
now the clip dropped all i'm fine you
ready
i'm ready
nice knowing you spider-man but excuse
me
the entire world's about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man everyone
uh can't some people still know that's
not how the spell works so my
girlfriend's just gonna forget about
everything we've been through i mean is
she even gonna be my girlfriend all
right fine okay
everyone in the world is gonna forget
that you're spider-man except your
girlfriend oh
there we go oh my god nick okay let's
not change the parameters of this spell
anymore while i'm okay i'm done i'm done
i swear i'm done i'm done
now but my aunt may should really know
dude just stop talking oh my gosh
wow
this guy and the guy at the bodega needs
to know that clip actually answered one
major critic one major criticism that a
lot of people were given a flack for
yeah when he's like can't tell you how
many times i've heard people be like who
did he just tell mj afterwards and show
her like i've heard that so many times
and then come to find out oh it's in the
movie
just seconds later
by everyone but mj we'll know like right
away it's already been thought out and
that breeds so much better because yeah
that was something that if you're
watching in trailer form i could see how
you can nitpick it in one group this
spell going wrong i i feel like it's
because peter was being kind of dumb i
could see how that criticism can come to
apply but the way this flows just has
that scene make a whole lot more sense
because he wasn't fully prepared for
exactly whatever the hell the spell was
going to be yeah
breathing room of this particular scene
puts you a bit more in peter's shoes so
it feels a little more like something we
might also do if we were in that
position of oh no wait wait wait wait
i've got so caught up to actually figure
out what the spell needs to be that i
forgot like oh these people need to know
it's because it's so natural to want to
be like oh everyone needs to forget but
wait i need to be smart about this i
need to be strategic about this and i'm
curious because of all the clips we've
seen and i know we've touched on this in
each one you know each one of them feels
like they have been kind of
conscientiously pared down and this one
felt the least like that to me i still
felt a bit of it a bit of it yeah yeah
so i'm still curious as to know what
else might be hidden there because it
still feels like they arrive at the
sanctum and then dr strange is just like
come on downstairs let's get this going
let's do this right away but that tv
spot though of the one of peter parker
calling into the daily bugle originally
to ask if he could get a photographer
job because that's the next stage in
evolution for peter parker is to become
a photographer the daily bug yes after
everything he's hit through that's the
logical next thing he changes subjects
all of a sudden it seems like this is
leading into right before the big finale
fight just based off of the way his face
is all messed up yeah leading into that
but the fact that he's like taking
ownership responsibility it seems like
he's warning the world because there's
gonna be a lot of big stakes that are
happening a lot of the world impending
things especially when you look at the
trailer with doctor strangers like i
can't stop them from coming through and
you're seeing some other clips that
they've been online of literally like it
seems like world shattering stuff is
occurring and the fact that he has to
like chime in and own up to this it's
interesting
responsibility
exactly exactly he's taking
responsibility for this it's kind of a
cool complimentary effect if the opening
of this movie is going to start off with
him you know being exposed by the daily
bugle to the world and now he's just
going to take it into his own hands so
he can control sort of the narrative
it's not really about controlling the
narrative it's that some bad thing is
going to be occurring he feels
personally responsible for this which a
lot of the marketing has really showed
that yeah a lot of the decision making
that has gone wrong has been based off
of his own guilt
which feels very spiderman i feel like
this will actually as much as there's
like a bunch of different villains and
other spider-man coming in this feels
like this will be the most spider-man
out of the tom holland ones for sure
just based off of his character alone
like the more clips we've been seeing
have gonna be more excited about tom
holland specifically yeah and especially
that ending beat of like you wish me
luck your friendly neighborhood
spider-man could use some like that was
a felt just the delivery of that felt
really human and to have it kind of
directly again acknowledge like yeah he
is the friendly neighborhood spider-man
i know that something like coy harps on
a lot is that down-to-earth sort of
world that spider-man feels most at home
in and yeah i really like that idea that
you have these compliments of he's
messing with great power in going and
tampering with magic trying to solve his
problems you know by bypassing you know
the real conflict and then ultimately
having to go to the place that is most
hostile towards him but he also probably
knows conscientiously is the one place
that will absolutely play anything yeah
so yeah it feels like a true ownership
of the moment and being like yeah you
know what i'm not even gonna try and
fight the image that jay jonah's putting
out there i'm just gonna send them this
message and i'm gonna you know yeah take
ownership of this multiversal madness
unleashed upon the world i'm really
looking forward to how the situation's
gonna unfold it seems like that fight
between dr strange and peter that
peter's gonna win that fight i don't
know how he'll win that fight i don't
know how spider-man can honestly be
doctor strange due to the fact that the
all the negative repercussions are gonna
be unfolding in the plot it would just
stand to reason that peter's gonna win
that fight i feel like spider-man can
either win it or it might be one of
those things where it just ends in some
kind of like they're jostling over this
cube prison and maybe it just breaks in
the process or something like that and
through this sort of struggle that peter
creates all hell breaks loose all right
guys well spider-man no way home this is
not the end of the tv spots and clips we
still got a few more days
leave your thoughts down below last but
not least let's do a
jn valente if there's anyone who belongs
in a place like the sanctum sanctorum
it's you i feel like you would be right
at home amid a swath of dusty volumes
from around the world specializing in
various schools of thought philosophy
magic alchemy etc think of the ways in
which you could harness the mysteries of
the universe and then you know smold
them in your own image and then when we
are down on our luck when this channel
has started to fail you can then do us a
solid by making sure that everyone in
the world knows who the real rejects are
and that spell could never go wrong
could never incur any kind of terrible
multiversal madness unless of course you
go off on one of your rambling tangents
in the middle of this spell which you
know is entirely possible but honestly i
think the outcome might be better if you
do that so jn
keep us in your thoughts and uh wherever
you are in the world i hope you're doing
well and uh i hope you're having a nice
end to the year holiday season
yeah
i would hate to be in the same room with
you two oh it's gonna be great